ςόχι καμπανάκαι εδώ και δεκαϊτίες κάποιες φορές τους αγνούμε κάποιες φορές θα φήνουμε τα πράγματα
να βάρουν μια εξελίξε όπ σαν το καμπάνα και αλλά είπαν και καλάλο για για
την βεβαίως μα γι αυτό έχουμε επιισαγωγικά ότι κυπρια γειονομία βρίσκετει σε μια πολύ καληφάσει
όμως υπάρχουν προκλίσεις και υπάρχουν θέατα όπως έχουμε πί στη μεραγματική οικονομία το δούνου του
βεβαίος έχει κάνει κ σωστά των εποπτικό τουρόλο και σαν ένας ξένος φορέας που σκοπό
έχει να δει πως μπορεί να εξελικθεί περιτέρω το κυπριακή οικονομα κλοι τον κόμμα δου
κινδίνου ιδικότερα όσον αφορά δα πάνες που δεν είναι παραγωγικές δηλαδή αύξηση του του μισθολογείου
του δημόσιο τομέα δεν θα υξισή την παραγωγικό ότητα ή θα πελτειώσει την οικονομία αλλά
θα διογκόσι να πρόβλημα που υπάρχει για πάρα πολλά χρονια και έχουν τονίσει το θέμα
του χάσματος μεταξύ το μιστών του ιδιωτικού τομια και του δημοσιοτομία και αυτό είναι ένα
διαχρονικό πρόβλημα που το δχριαζε κατρία μέσα στον νημόνιο υπήρχε μια ξεκάθεριρητί η εντολή για
να γίνου μελέτες και να βελτιωθεί αυτό και δεν είχε γίνει ποτέτο δεκατρί όμως και
στον δημόσιο αλλά και στων διωτικό έχει να θυσίες από τους εργάζομε βεβαίως αλλά πάντα
αυτή που πληρώνου το μεγαλύτερο λογαριασμό είναι υπαλίο δ του ιδιοτικου δομέα ξέρουμε ότι υπάρχει
και μι προστασία ευρίτερι στον δημόσιο τομέα τουλάχιστον υπεεξε ι επαναφορά των μισθον το ύο
χριδιάδεσκοστρία χει γίνει επαναφορά δομισθόν λίγο πριν τες προηγούμενες εκλογίες άρα θα έλεγα ότι σίγουρα
αυτή που έχουν χάσει περισότερο είναι ιτο προσωπικό στο τον ιδιοτικόδομέα ακριβώς και μέσα σε
ενώρα αυτά ακομό έχουμε και τις εξαγγελίες τ καθημερινά δεν ξέρεις τι ναπεριμένεις και μια
ανακοίνωση του φέρνει τόμινο τόσος θα χρηματιστήρια όσο και στις αγορές πάγκοσμα ξεκάθαρα το ο
τράμ θέλει εί αυνα αυτό ου εχε υποσχεθεί ι δηλαδή να κάνει την αμερική μεγάλη